I love that you said Ordinary People was
an inspiration for this film do you have
any other kind of non-horror
works in film TV or books that you lean
on when you're creating these stories of
anything I could say is unique about
what I bring to horror it's that I love
you know from the kind of artist our
house to the shockiest horror and like
my references are all over yeah one of
the movies that we were talking about
and referencing for this I mean Sophie
was um
three colors blue you know the the
kislovsky movie which is all about going
through loss and and alienating yourself
from people as a response to loss and
there's there's even uh shots from three
colors blue that I've taken and turned
into horror beats there's a scene in the
basement where she's uh seeing the
shadow of the boogeyman through these
rolled up bits of parchment paper so
that's a straight lift from three colors
blue we just make it scary so you're
able to map it over yeah I'm always
trying to find always trying to find um
uh yeah I want to be pulling from all
sorts of different references